a couple of videos ago we introduced the
idea of a length of the length of a
vector that equals the length and this
was a neat idea because we're used to
the the length of things in two or three
dimensional space but it becomes very
abstract when we get to n dimensions if
this has a hundred components at least
for me it's hard to visualize a hundred
dimension vector but we've actually
defined its notion of length and we saw
that this is actually a scalar value
it's a scalar value it's just a number
in this video I want to attempt to
define the notion of an angle of an
angle between vectors between vectors
between vectors as you can see we're
building up this mathematics of vectors
from the ground up and we can't just say
oh I know that an angle is because
everything we know about angles and even
lengths it just applies to what we
associate with two or three dimensional
space but the whole study of linear
algebra is subtracting these at these
ideas into multi dimensional space and I
haven't even defined what dimension is
yet but I think you understand that idea
to some degree already when people talk
about one or two or three dimensions so
let's let's say that I have some vector
let's say I have two vectors vectors a
and B vectors a and B they're nonzero
and they're members of RN they're
members of RN and they're non-zero and I
don't have a notion of of their of the
angle between them yet but let me let me
just draw them out let me just draw them
as if I could draw them in two
dimensions so that would be vector a
right there maybe that's vector B right
there and then this vector right there
would be the vector a minus B and you
can verify that just the way we've
learned to add and subtract vectors or
you know this is heads to tails so B
plus a minus B is of course going to be
vector a and that all just works out
there to help to help us define this
notion of angle let me construct another
triangle that's going to look a lot like
this one but remember this is just
doing this for for our our simple minds
to imagine it in two dimensions but
these aren't necessarily two-dimensional
beasts these could be each these each
could have 100 components but let me go
make another triangle let me make
another triangle that looks something
well it should look similar it should be
say it looks like that
and I'm going to define the size of the
triangles to be the lengths of each of
these vectors remember the lengths of
each of these vectors I don't care how
many components they are they're just
going to be your numbers so the length
of this side right here is just going to
be the length of a the length of this
side right here it's just going to be
the length of vector a minus vector B
minus vector B and the length of this
side right here is going to be the
length of vector B now the first thing
we want to make sure is that we can
always construct a triangle like that
and so what under what circumstances
could we not construct a triangle like
this well we wouldn't be able to
construct a triangle like this if if
this side if if B if the magnitude so
let me write this down it's kind of a
subtle point but I want make this very
clear we want to in order to define an
angle I want to be comfortable that I
can always make this construction and I
need to be I need to make sure that let
me write reasons why I couldn't reasons
reasons why I couldn't make this
construction well what if the magnitude
of B was greater than or the length of
vector B was greater than the length of
vector a plus the length of vector a
minus B I couldn't in two dimensions I
could never draw a triangle like that
then because you would have this length
Plus this length would be shorter than
this thing right here and so you could
never construct it and I could do it
with all the sides what if this length
was larger than one of these two sides
or what if that length was larger than
one of those two sides I could just
never draw a two-dimensional rect a
triangle that way so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to use the triangle the
vector triangle inequality to prove that
each of these sides is less than or
equal to the sum of the other sides
and you know I could let me see I could
do the same thing let me make the point
clear I could show that you know if a
for whatever reason was greater than the
other sides plus B then I wouldn't be
able to create a triangle and the last
one of course is if a minus B for
whatever reason was greater than the
other two sides I just wouldn't be able
to draw a triangle an A plus B so I need
to show that for any vectors that are
any real vectors nonzero real vectors or
members RN that none of these can ever
happen I need to prove that none of
those can happen so what does triangle
inequality tell us the triangle
inequality tells us that if I have the
sum of two vectors let me if I take the
length of the sum of two vectors that
that is always going to be less than and
these are nonzero vectors this is always
going to be less than or equal to the
sum of each of their individual lengths
this thumb of each of their individual
lengths so let's see if we can apply
that to this triangle right here so what
is the magnitude the the length of a the
length of a well I can rewrite vector a
what is vector a equal to vector a is
equal to vector B plus vector a minus B
right this is just I mean I'm just
rewriting the vector here I'm just
rewriting a here as the sum of the other
two vectors nothing fancy there I
haven't used the triangle inequality or
anything I've just used my definition of
vector addition but here now I've if I
put little parentheses here now I can
apply the triangle inequality I say well
you know what this is going to be by the
triangle inequality which we proved it's
going to be less than or equal to the
lengths of each of these vectors vector
B plus the length of vector a minus B so
we know that a is a the length of a is
less than the sum of that one in that
one so we don't have to worry about this
being our problem we know that that is
not true now let's look at
at be so is there any way that I can
rewrite B is the sum of two other
vectors well sure I can write it as the
sum of a as the sum of a plus plus let
me put it this way if that vector right
there is a minus B the the same vector
in the reverse direction is going to be
the vector B minus a so a plus the
vector B minus a that's the same thing
as B in it you can see it right here the
A's would cancel out and you're just
left with a B there now by the by the
triangle inequality we know that this is
less than or equal to the length of
vector a plus the length of vector B
minus a now you're saying hey Sal this
you're dealing with B minus a this is
the length of a minus B and I could
leave this two for you to prove it based
on our definition of vector lengths but
the length of B minus a B minus a is
equal to minus one times a minus B and
I'll leave it to you to say that look
these the these lengths are equal
because essentially well I won't I won't
I could leave that but I think you can
you can take that based on just the the
visual depiction of them that they're
the exact same vectors just in different
directions and I have to be careful with
length because it's not just in two
dimensions but I think you get the idea
and I think you know I'll leave that for
you to prove that these lengths are the
same thing so we know that B is less
than the length of those two things so
we don't have to worry about that one
right there
finally a minus B can we write that the
magnitude or the length the length of
vector a minus B well I can write that
as the length of or I could write that
as vector A plus vector minus B right
you could say if vector right if we just
put a minus B right there and go in
other directions we could say - be which
would be in that direction plus a would
give us our vector a minus B and that's
obvi actually I don't even have to go
there that's obvious from this I just
kind of put the negative in the
parenthesis well the triangle inequality
and this might seem a little mundane to
you but it really shows us that we can
always define a regular planar triangle
based on these vectors in this way tells
us this is less than or equal to the
length of our vector a plus the length
of minus B and I just said and you could
prove it to yourself that this is the
same thing as the length of B so we just
saw that this is definitely less than
those two this is less definite less
than those two and that is definitely
less than those two so we don't have we
none of the reasons that would keep us
from constructing a triangle or Vallot
so we can always construct a triangle in
this way from any arbitrary nonzero
vectors in r n we can always construct
this now to define an angle let me let
me redraw it down here let me redraw the
vectors maybe a little bit bigger
that's vector a I'll draw it slightly
this is vector B and then let me just
draw it this way this is the vector
right there that is the vector a minus B
and we said we're going to define a
corresponding regular run-of-the-mill
vanilla triangle whose lengths are
defined by the lengths of the vectors by
the vector length so this is the length
of B that's side this is the length of a
minus B and then this is the length of a
now now that I know that can always
construct a triangle like this I can
attempt to define or luxury I will
define my definition of an angle between
two vectors so we know what an angle
means in this context this is just a
regular run-of-the-mill geometric
triangle now my definition of an angle
between two vectors I'm going to say so
this is what I'm trying to define this
is what I'm going to define because
these can be these can have arbitrary
number of components it's hard to
visualize but I'm going to define
this angle as the corresponding angle in
a regular run-of-the-mill triangle where
the sides of the run in the middle
triangle are the two vectors and then
the opposite side is the subtraction is
the length of the difference between the
two vectors this is just the definition
I'm just saying that these two things
I'm defining this the angle between two
vectors in RN that could have an
arbitrary number of components I'm
defining this angle to be the same as
this angle the angle between the two
sides the two lengths of those vectors
in just a regular run-of-the-mill
triangle now what can I do with this
well we find a relationship between all
of these things right here well sure if
you remember from your trigonometry
class and if you don't we have a I've
proved it in their playlist you have the
law of cosines law of cosines and I'll
do it with an arbitrary triangle right
here just because I don't want to
confuse you so if this is side a B and C
and this is Theta the law of cosines
tells us that C squared is equal to a
squared plus B squared minus 2a B cosine
of theta I always think of it as kind of
a more a broader Pythagorean theorem
because it doesn't this thing does not
have to be a right angle it accounts for
all angles if this becomes a right angle
then this term disappears and you're
just left with the Pythagorean theorem
but we've proven this this applies to
just regular run-of-the-mill triangles
and lucky for us we have a regular
run-of-the-mill
triangle here so let's let's apply the
law of cosines to this triangle right
here so we would get if you know in the
way I drew it they correspond the length
of this side squared so that means the
length of a minus B squared the the
length of vector a minus vector B that's
just the length of that side so I'm just
squaring that side it equals it equals
the length of vector B squared plus the
length of vector a squared
- two times the length of I'll just
write two times length of vector a times
the length of vector B times the cosine
of this angle right here times the
cosine of that angle and I'm defining
this angle between these two vectors to
be the same as this angle right there so
we know this angle by definition we know
that angle right there well we know that
the square of our lengths of a vector
when we use our vector definition of
length that this is just the same thing
as the vector dotted with itself so
that's a minus B dot a minus B and it's
all going to be equal to this whole
stuff on the right-hand side but let me
simplify the left-hand side of this
equation a minus B dot a minus B this is
the same thing as a dot a right those
two terms minus a dot B minus a dot B
and then I have minus B dot a minus B
dot a that's those two terms right there
and then you have the minus B minus B
that's the same thing as a plus B dot B
remember this is just a simplification
of the left-hand side and I can rewrite
this a dot a we know that's just the
length of a squared a dot B and B dot a
are the same thing so we have two of
these so this right here this term right
there will simplify to minus two times a
dot B and then finally B dot B we know
that that's just the length of B squared
now I just simplified or maybe I just
expanded that's a better word I you
can't when you go from a one term here
to three terms you can't say you
simplified it but I expand to just the
left-hand side and so this has to be
equal to the right-hand side by the law
of cosines so that is equal to that is
equal to I almost feel like instead of
rewriting it let me just copy and paste
it so if I just
if I just do what did I just do copy and
then edit copy and paste there you go
and if that was worth it but maybe I
saved a little bit of time so that is
equal to that right there and then we
can simplify we have a length of a
squared here length of a squared there
subtract it from both sides length of B
squared here length of B squared there
subtract it from both sides and then if
what what can we do we can get we can
Multan divide both sides by -2 because
all everything else has disappeared and
so that term and that term will both
become ones and all we're left with is
the vector a dot the vector B and this
is interesting because all of a sudden
we were getting a relationship between
the dot products of two vectors we've
kind of gone away from their definition
by lengths but that the dot product of
two vectors is equal to the product of
their lengths is equal to the product of
their lengths their vector lengths and
they can have an arbitrary number of
components times the cosine of the angle
between them remember this theta I said
this is the same as when you draw this
kind of analogous regular triangle but
I'm defining the angle between them to
be the same as that so I can say that
this is the angle between them and
obviously the idea of between two
vectors it's hard to visualize if you go
beyond three dimensions but now we have
it at least mathematically defined angle
between them so if you give me two
vectors we can now using this formula
that we proved using the definite this
definition up here we can add the
calculate the the angle between any two
vectors using this right here and just
to make it clear what happens when what
happens if a is a is a is a and maybe
it's not clear from that definition so
I'll make it clear here that by
definition if a is equal to some scalar
multiple of B where
C is greater than zero will define will
define theta to be equal to zero and if
C is less than zero so a is collinear
but goes in the exact opposite direction
will define theta to be equal to 180
degrees and that's consistent with what
we understand about just two-dimensional
two-dimensional vectors if they're
collinear and kind of the scalar
multiples the same that means a look
something like that and B looks
something like that so you say that's a
zero angle and if they go the other way
if a looks something like this is the
case where a is just going in the other
direction from B a goes like that and B
goes like that we define the angle
between them to be 180 degrees but
everything else is pretty well defined
by the triangle example I had to make
the special case of these because it's
not clear you really get a triangle in
these cases because then the triangle
kind of disappears it flattens out if a
and B are on top of each other if
they're going in the exact opposite
direction so that's why I wanted to make
a little bit of a side note a little bit
of a side note right there now we can
using this definition of the angle
between the vectors we can now define
the idea of perpendicular vectors so we
can now say perpendicular vectors this
is another definition perpendicular
perpendicular and this won't be
earth-shattering but it kind of is
because we've generalized this two
vectors of that have an arbitrary number
of components we're defining
perpendicular mean the theta between so
perpendicular to vectors a and B are
perpendicular and B are perpendicular if
the angle between them between them is
90 degrees and we can define that we can
take two vectors dot prod them take
their dot product figure out their two
lengths and then you could figure out
their angle between them and if it's 90
degrees you can say that they are
perpendicular angles and I want to be
very clear here that this is actually
not defined for the zero vector right
here
so this situation this situation right
here not defined for the zero vector
because if you have the zero vector then
this quantity right here is going to be
zero and then this quantity right here
is going to be zero and there's no clear
definition for your angle right if this
is zero right here you did is equal to
zero times cosine of theta and so if you
wanted to solve for theta you'd get
cosine of theta is equal to zero over
zero which is undefined undefined
undefined but what we can do is create a
slightly more general word than the word
perpendicular so the perpendicular meet
you have to have a defined angle to even
talk about perpendicular if the angle
between two vectors is 90 degrees we're
saying by definition those two vectors
are perpendicular but what if we made
the statement and we can we if you look
at them if the angle between two vectors
is 90 degrees what does that mean what
does that mean so let's say that theta
is 90 degrees let me draw a line here
let's say that theta is 90 degrees theta
is equal to 90 degrees what is that what
does this formula tell us it tells us
that a dot B is equal to the length of a
time's the length of B times cosine of
90 degrees well what's cosine of 90
degrees it's zero you can review your
unit circle if that that doesn't make a
lot of sense but that is equal to zero
so this whole term is going to be equal
to zero
so if theta is equal to 90 degrees then
a dot B is equal to zero and so this is
another interesting interesting takeaway
if a and B are perpendicular
perpendicular then their dot product is
going to be equal to zero now if their
dot product is equal to zero can we
necessarily say that they are
perpendicular well what if they're what
if what if a or b is is the zero vector
right the zero vector let me call Z for
zero vector
you know I could just draw the you know
the what if you know the zero vector dot
anything is always going to be equal to
zero so does that mean that the zero
vector is perpendicular everything well
no because the zero vector I said that
we have to have the notion of of an
angle between things in order to use the
word perpendicular so we can't use the
zero vector
we can't we can't say just because two
vectors dot products are equal to zero
that they are perpendicular and that's
because the zero vector would mess that
up because the zero vector is not
defined but if we say and we have been
saying that a and B are not zero if they
are you know non zero vectors non zero
then we can say that if a and B are
nonzero and their dot product is equal
to zero then a and B are perpendicular
so now it goes both ways but what if we
just have this condition right here what
if we just have the condition that a dot
B is equal to zero it seems like that's
kind of just a simple pure condition and
we can write a word for that and these
words are often used synonymously but
hopefully you understand the distinction
now we can say that if the two if two
vectors dot product is equal zero
we will call them orthogonal orthogonal
as I always say spelling is into my my
best subject but this is kind of a neat
idea this tells us that D well that all
perpendicular vectors are orthogonal and
it also tells us that the zero vector so
zero vector is orthogonal orthogonal to
everything else to everything even to
itself right the 0 dot 0 vector you
still get 0 so by definition its
orthogonal so for the first time
probably in your mathematical career
you're seeing that the words you know
every time you first got exposed to the
words perpendicular and orthogonal in
geometry or maybe in physics or wherever
else there were always kind of the same
words but now I'm introducing a nice
little
distinction here and you can kind of you
know be a little smart aleck with with
teachers oh is it you know it's
perpendicular only if the vectors aren't
you know if neither of them are zero
vector otherwise if their dot product is
zero you can only say that they're
orthogonal but if they're nonzero you
could say that they're orthogonal and
perpendicular but anyway I thought that
I would introduce this little
distinction for you in case you have
someone who likes to trip you up with
words but it also I think highlight that
we are building a mathematics from the
ground up and we have to be careful
about the words we use and we have to be
very precise about our definitions
because we're not precise about our
definitions and we build up a bunch of
mathematics on top of this and do a
bunch of proofs one day we might scratch
our heads and and reach some type of
weird ambiguity and it might have all
came out of the fact that we weren't
precise enough in defining what some of
these terms mean well anyway hopefully
you found this useful we can now take
the angle or we can now determine the
angle between vectors with an arbitrary
number of components